je suis né à orléans et je mets racines
encore sa hutte chan dans la montagne
mes grands-parents les fonctionnaires et
des ouvriers devenus patrons grâce à
l'école j'ai quatre enfants et chaque
matin je pense à leur avenir je ne suis
pas le plus connu mais je suis celui qui
vous comprends je m'appelle philippe
juvin je suis médecin et toute ma vie je
travaillais avec des personnes dévouées
au service des autres des femmes et des
hommes engagés qui protège et duke swan
servent et aide nos compatriotes leur
tâche est immense car la souffrance
s'amplifie chaque jour
parallèlement à ma vie médecin je suis
maire depuis vingt ans j'ai été député
européen pendant dix ans j'ai même été
militaire en afghanistan contre les
talibans toutes ces expériences je veux
les mettre au service de notre pays ça
fait 40 ans que la france est malade
comme médecin et quand mr je vois que
nous sommes devenus plus pauvres que nos
voisins que nos services publics ferment
que l'état est de plus en plus directif
et de moins en moins efficace nous ne
sommes plus protégé la violence explose
partout même notre ère et notre
alimentation se dégrade et pendant ce
temps là que font les hommes politiques
ils commentent ils composent toujours
les mêmes vieilles recettes
pour eux qu'ils seront toujours à l'abri
la politique c'est d'abord une rente
cela assez dur et nous devons tout
changer
il est temps de reprendre le contrôle
sur cette bureaucratie qui nous étouffe
sur ses décisions qui se prennent tout à
paris sur ce mépris pour tous ceux qui
ne viennent pas de la bonne école ou du
bon quartier c'est pour apporter des
solutions que je suis candidat à
l'élection présidentielle
je mettrai fin au désordre je redonnerai
à la france sa place dans le monde je
simplifierait toute cette norme et
paperasse qui nous asphyxie jeu
moderniserait les services publics je
reconstruirai notre recherche et notre
industrie qui nous ont bradé
j'accélérais la transition écologique et
j'améliorais notre alimentation je
lutterai contre l'ignorance et je
réaliserai notre école je ferai en sorte
que chaque français est un médecin pour
se soigner et un toit pour s'abriter
j'aiderai d'abord ceux qui veulent s'en
sortir j'aurais considéré les français
je laisserais s'épanouir les talents de
chacun je ferai confiance aux élus
locaux aux chercheurs aux entrepreneurs
aux bénévoles aux agriculteurs à tous
ceux qui se lèvent tôt à tous ceux qui
nous protège à tous ceux qui nous éduque
et à tous ceux qui sont sur le terrain
le moment est venu il est temps de
reprendre le contrôle
[Musique]